pues de uno de los vídeos pasados acerca
de bancos recibió un comentario acerca
de lo siguiente si todos meten su oro en
el banco que pueden utilizar para hacer
transacciones cómo pueden comprar
comidas o pagar servicios bueno esta
pregunta es una excelente manera de
introducir el término de nota bancaria
de nota bancaria y esto de aquí pues a
lo mejor ya lo has escuchado antes no sé
en alguna novela de charles dickens o
algo así pero vamos a ver en este vídeo
que de hecho es un concepto mucho más
familiar de lo que crees probablemente
incluso tengas algunas de estas notas
bancarias en tu cartera bueno entonces
vamos a regresar al ejemplo del banco de
sal digamos que no se había iniciado con
100 piezas de oro como capital tenía un
capital de 100 piezas de oro 100 piezas
de oro y usé eso para construir un
edificio entonces él así empieza se las
paga constructores que no viven en la
aldea y entonces ya no la deposita en el
banco ahí está el edificio
y luego todos los aldeanos hicieron sus
depósitos de sus ahorros en mi edificio
que es como se ve muy sólido y muy
seguro dijeron a esta patria y entonces
ellos depositaron mil piezas de oro para
entonces voy a dibujarlo por acá es la
parte derecha de mi hoja de balance y
son 1000 piezas de oro entonces al lado
derecho en mis pasivos tengo mil piezas
de oro va debo mil piezas de oro debo
milk
piezas de oro y en el lado de los
activos pues recibo esas piezas de oro
no voy a poner por acá ahí están los
activos que están extrañamente
inclinados como la torre de pizza bueno
no importa en el lado de los activos
tengo las mil piezas de oro mil piezas
de oro por el momento están simplemente
reposando ahí en mis bóvedas ahora la
pregunta es si todas las personas
dejaron el dinero en el mismo vedas que
pueden utilizar para hacer transacciones
en el día a día puede saber voy a poner
aquí que son activos acá voy a poner que
son pasivos verdad lo debo por eso son
pasivos son mil piezas que pueden
reclamar cuando quieran estoy aquí lo
podemos pensar como una cuenta de
cheques pero después después vamos a
hablar de eso ahora esas mil piezas
están depositadas en mi bóveda que
podemos hacer para que puedan hacer
transacciones pues la solución es la
siguiente sabes que en vez de tomar un
poquito de tu oro y usar eso para hacer
transacciones
eso suena algo complicado porque no
simplemente te doy una
una nota que diga tú pusiste tanta
cantidad de dinero en el banco entonces
por ejemplo supongamos que para cada
pieza de oro cada pieza de oro una pieza
voy a voy a emitir una nota bancaria y
esa nota bancaria la voy a poner aquí
una nota bancaria pendiente nota
bancaria pendiente no sabe muy bien pero
hay de ese nota bancaria pendiente y
luego te voy a dar un papelito y ese
papelito se va a ver más o menos así y
está aquí ya ya va a aparecer te un poco
más conocido entonces tiene una forma
rectangular que quepa bien en las
carteras algo de ese estilo tiene una
bonita foto de sal a la mitad porque es
el fundador del banco y tiene una
denominación de una pieza de oro una
pieza de oro una pieza de oro
una pieza de oro va entonces si tú
llegas y me das una pieza de oro a
cambio yo te doy este pedazo de papel
algo muy importante es que es un papel
que solo yo sé cómo imprimir tiene
seguridad muy muy sofisticada no sé tal
vez yo por ahí le puse la firma y dice
sal y por acá puse un dibujito que solo
yo sé hacer y le puse hologramas y
muchísimos dispositivos de seguridad que
no sean tan caros verdad que valga la
pena pero nadie más la puede falsificar
entonces estoy aquí esencialmente es un
pedazo de papel que dice sabes que
cualquier persona que tenga este pedazo
puede venir al banco y obtener una pieza
de oro de mi bóveda me da el papel y yo
le doy una pieza de oro ahora como todos
en la aldea confían en que el banco de
sal es mis pues tiene una muy buena
reputación y siempre va a cambiar ese
papel por un pedazo de oro en vez de
usar oro para comprar cosas pues nada
más va a usar estas notas bancarias para
hacer transacciones y más aún a lo mejor
no queremos nada más tener pues notas
bancarias de uno a lo mejor quieres
llegar y depositar cinco piezas de oro
en mi banco lo voy a hacer con otro
color entonces a lo mejor llega si
depositas cinco piezas de oro
practicidad lo que voy a hacer no quedo
proporcional pero ya ni modo jaja
entonces por practicidad lo que voy a
hacer es emitir una nota bancaria de
cinco piezas de oro nota bancaria
pendiente de cinco piezas de oro
entonces para certificarlo te doy pues
creo que ya adivinaste verdad voy a
hacerlo con otro color porque estas
notas bancarias pues pueden venir en
varios colores va entonces otra vez
tiene la foto de alguien famoso no sé
quién es muy difícil de falsificar
hologramas y todo y entonces tiene una
denominación de cinco piezas de oro va
es una nota bancaria de cinco piezas de
oro entonces pues si ahora eres un
aldeano y me depositás tu dinero además
de intereses y seguridad obtienes estas
notas bancarias que son bien difíciles
de falsificar y este es un punto así
súper clave es para que alguien ajeno al
banco o a la aldea no pueda ir e
imprimir un montón de estas y hacer un
fraude entonces estamos suponiendo que
son súper seguras ahora si no sólo
tienes interés y seguridad sino que
además obtienes
este medio de intercambio que es mucho
más fácil de utilizar que el oro déjame
hacer una nota un poco más grande una de
500 piezas de oro que si alguien me da
500 piezas de oro le voy a emitir una
nota bancaria de después de 500 piezas
de oro una nota bancaria pendiente eso
sería mi pasivo verdad porque en algún
punto alguien puede llegar y devolverme
esa nota bancaria y yo le tendría que
devolver 500 piezas de oro pues por eso
es un pasivo entonces no sé voy a
dibujar esta nota bancaria en color
naranja y dice 500 500 500 todos estos
son 500 piezas de oro va otra vez a
alguien famoso lo que sea
primero observa esto de aquí es súper
útil ahora mi banco este bueno el banco
ya vimos que aumenta el dinero y ayuda
al desarrollo y todo verdad ayuda a
producir y hacer crecer la economía pero
ahora ya encontramos otra cosa útil que
un banco podría hacer además de guardar
el dinero de dar intereses y de hacer
crecer la economía puede proveer una
unidad
intercambio que es más fácil de utilizar
que el oro imagina puedes ir por la vida
y contando 500 piezas de oro cada vez
que quieras pagarlas o tener que andar
cargando las balanzas muy en práctico
con estos papelitos simplemente podemos
contar y eso de ahí ya es dinero ya es
efectivo bueno a lo mejor hábitat vas a
estar como sospechando un poco y debes
decir espera un momento esto se ve como
un billete de 10 pesos o lo que sea de
20 pesos de días ya no existe en verdad
y eso es cierto porque porque o sea de
hecho los billetes si son otras
bancarias pero del gobierno federal
antes hace mucho tiempo como en la época
colonial teníamos un montón de bancos en
las cenas en las colonias y cada uno de
ellos se emitía sus notas bancarias
entonces no había pues un método de pago
único había banco no se estaba el banco
de sal y estaba el banco el banco de
benito estrada o lo que sea entonces las
personas pues tenían que hacer
intercambios entre un banco y otro y era
muy complicado
no estamos tan familiarizados con el
término nota bancaria porque solo vemos
un tipo o al menos un tipo por cada país
únicamente vemos notas bancarias de un
banco de cada país y ese banco en los
países desarrollados usualmente es el
banco federal en méxico es el banco de
méxico- y bueno después vamos a hablar
un poco más de en donde está respaldado
este dinero porque no necesariamente es
oro usualmente son bienes nacionales
pero vamos a hablar de eso después es
bien interesante lo que quería contarte
ahorita es esto de que un banco puede
emitir notas bancarias que se pueden
usar como efectivo y esto es un poco
distinto de las cuentas de cheques de
las cuales voy a platicar en el
siguiente vídeo después voy a usar ambos
conceptos para volver a hacer el ejemplo
que hicimos con préstamos para canales y
la fábrica para mostrarte que de hecho
el oro no tiene por qué salir del banco
el oro puede quedarse seguro en las
bóvedas mientras que el banco usa sus
notas bancarias y cuentas de cheques
para realizar las transacciones nos
vemos